hey guys Sam here hope you having a
wonderful week let's make it even better
by talking about the new defenders
breaking it down find every Easter again
every nook and cranny of every scene the
newest Netflix Marvel collaborative
series is the culmination of five
seasons of solo shows two daredevil one
of Jessica Jones one of Luke Cage and
one of iron fist while these shows have
been dealing with their individual
threats we've also been teased a big bed
that can't be taken down by just one
hero No
they'll need to join forces to feed the
nefarious hands basically a group of
evil Undead they just but I'm giving you
a head of myself censor women through
eight episodes let's break this down
into sections now here's the official
spoiler warning for the defenders and
all the Marvel Netflix shows and their
possible future seasons before I get too
far out of myself I got to say that this
defenders opening theme might be my
favorite out of all the shows it's tied
with Daredevils waxey and show but I
just love how the show unders Douglas
Petry and Marcus Ramirez merged all four
shows so well not only are we seeing
each of the heroes overlaid with street
maps of New York some of them with their
specific neighborhoods underneath them
but they also paint them with the color
palette of their shows sure you guys
know that right away but when you listen
carefully the theme of the defenders has
some hints to each of the other
defenders theme songs so cool not only
that but you can also see some classic
pairings of Heroes but I'll come back to
that in a second let's keep this video
offering our classic Marvel Comics
Easter eggs little hints and nods to
these characters or digital comic books
and series right off the bat we get
Danny and Colleen fighting a hood and
Electra hit the sewers
electronic on the head well yes and if
we take a look back at her comic history
in the movie we see that she was killed
by bullseye and subsequently resurrected
by the hand now the MCU has switched
this up just a little bit with her being
killed and revived by the hand but the
after-effects are roughly the same for
her time electro ran around devoid of
her personality and memories but in the
comics instead of hunting down these
street-level heroes she teams up with
Wolverine my way if you ask what the
black sky is in the comments down below
it's not from the comics so your guess
is good is mine I started to believe
that this was the hands version of the
iron fist but nothing really backs that
up at all so basically the box guys is
two superpowers individual controlled by
or in control
and I wish there was a better answer to
also it's worth mentioning who this guy
is who's died on the ground the sewer we
later get confirmation that this man is
another force fighting against the hand
not from Kremlin or associated with
behind your fist this gentleman was a
member of the chase named shaft he's not
the biggest character in the comments
but who hears the chaste group and then
just who broke off from the hand of
course and strive to stop the hand at
any cost
they're usually run by a character you
all know and probably love and at the
same time they stick now I've said all
this something you might already know
because one thing confuses me we see
many members of the chaise dead and
being dissolved with acid and stick
mentioned that he is the last of the
chase but what about this guard of
gentleman from daredevil season one
quick flip through the comic world can
tell us that this is stone a major
player in the chase but also an
important character who Elks resurrect
Elektra and help her regain for Humanity
he's an interesting guy and I might be a
little peeved if he just died somewhere
off screen and we never explore his
character but anyways we then flash
through the intro graphic where we get
the first nod to a couple awesome Marvel
team-up first up we see Iron Fist
standing underneath Luke Cage hinting to
their eventual team up and the Heroes
for Hire comic a comic that's usually
led by Luke Cage and Iron Fist where
people can hire out these superheroes to
do anything originally it was a solo
Luke Cage series but the most recently
Cage and Iron Fist comics showcased some
awesome team up stories between the two
of them now personally Iron Fist isn't
my favorite defender I get that he's
meant to be this cocky kid who learns a
thing or two humbles up becomes a
pleasant here then we can all root more
but I'm just not sold on him yet however
any scene where he and Luke Cage are
talking in this series I'm a fan of him
I know we're getting on for season two
but maybe just make it a Heroes for Hire
season well see Jessica Jones and Luke
Cage standing side by side in the
opening graphic this is clearly a nod to
their relationship in the Jessica Jones
the season one but also in the comics
both of these characters are actually
married in the comics and we get a
little nod to this in series I
appreciate how they patch up their
friendship and don't drag all the other
characters down with them but also
leaves an open to a possible
relationship in the future Aki
let's get some coffee sometimes
our series gets me even more excited
mainly because Luke and Jessica's
daughter in the comics is named Danielle
ringabel
that's right they named their daughter
after Danny ran I think we need a team
up series that can really hammer out
Danny and Luke's friendship and get us
on board with them naming their baby
after their friend name or sense last
thing I want to bring up you see an iron
fist in daredevil stand side-by-side it
gave the title as well we also get a
glimpse of Danny pulling a daredevil
boobies on a rooftop during the final
episode now matt has taken a break from
being daredevil many times in the comics
and has had many people take up the
daredevil mantle one other thing most
famous being Black Panther whose mashup
costume I do enjoy things a bit but also
you guessed it on your fist could any be
the new defender of house kitchen could
this be the next step to becoming a hero
that we all love and can actually you
know make a difference don't mind that
idea at all maybe it'll just inspire
them to be in vigilante but it would be
kind of interesting for them to take up
the mantle of daredevil wait and see but
anywho comic book Easter eggs let's get
going we see that Trish makes an
appearance yay but no Hellcat costume
whoo okay you say Oh who's that well
Trish usually takes on the superhero
persona of Hellcat and patrols the
streets of NYC she's actually one of the
bigger players in the current Marvel
Comics universe so it wouldn't be the
worst idea for Marvel Studios to cash in
on her fandom give her that costume too
while you're at it
daredevil can wear horns and she can get
hurt use and whiskers and claws it's the
worst idea that's getting forward a
little bit the conclusion of episode 2
mean right hook we see Matt Murdock come
to Jessica's a sure she didn't see that
coming but this is actually a throwback
to Jessica's original comic Oprah series
alias
replacements tonight with just some
regular non superhero cops and Matt
enters the interrogation room to
represent Miss Jones the scenes almost
mirror each other including the dialogue
pretty cool moving on to episode 4 the
world dragon baguette Luke mentioning
the Superfriends hey there you go a
Marvel DC crossover that's all you're
gonna get I know I've mentioned this
before but for those of you who missed
it the Superfriends used to be a show
made by hanna-barbera where it starts
Superman Batman the flash one ruin etc
also Danny Wayne complements met on his
vigilante skills when they're powwowing
was stick I'm gonna take this as another
hint that
you will either seek out the vigilante
lifestyle or take over the daredevil
mantle sense most of the world believes
that the devil of Hell's Kitchen is dead
maybe now one thing I wanted to mention
that this show kind of glossed over
stick refers to the hand of being kicked
out of : as Lucifer being cast out of
heaven more or less find this analogy
sort of interesting since Moon Moon is
one of these seven capital cities of
heaven these are cities that exist on
other planes in reality but pop up on
earth every few years I don't think they
posted a schedule after the big battle
in the Royal dragon huh the only battle
inside of a dragon wing thing that's
coming up soon the team captures so one
day one of the fingers of the hand and
they head to a theater fun fact time
when Luke Cage debuted his main base of
operation was an abandoned theater near
times in New York although there are
some bad memories in this particular
fear throughout the season we could see
it return and Luke Cage season two so
keep your eyes peeled excuse you for
just a little bit when we see Elektra
super kill Alexandra this is a nod to a
large chunk of Electra's history being
in charge of the hand sure it might be
short lived in this series but if Maddie
made it out of that whole building
falling apart on top of them I'm gonna
get so did she speak of surprises
there's a freaking dragon skeleton
underneath New York so I'm just guessing
the dragons and grant you know magic
calling fesai immortality maybe
sometimes telekinesis
no nothing like this in the comics but
there are definitely different types of
dragons that pop up in Marvel Comics you
get the same thing as a one of the
biggest ones all those tend to feel like
an alien
then there's the dragon of the moon
who's also kind of an alien slash demon
but who is this specific dragon probably
none of those but the thing to look
forward to with this reveal is the
possibility of an actual dragon
appearing in season 2 of Iron Fist I
mean it's a part of his whole gimmick
need one just crawling around blowing
fire you know the deal
now during our final battle our beloved
mr. Knight loses our arm Jax but not all
so bad because we're coming but
counterpart is famous for her bionic arm
now her original backstory has this bomb
going off at a police station which you
know cause looser armour than Tony Stark
gives her with a new
then mr. Knight loses her job at the
police station then teams up with
calling wing and a bunch of other Marvel
heroes now in the world Netflix she
loses her arm just before a large
explosion in New York with a bunch of
police around and she's probably
definitely maybe losing her job after
this since you know she kind of led a
bunch of vigilantes escaping blow
skyscraper in downtown with confiscated
evidence but we're left with the ray of
hope and Colleen says something about
Danny possibly helping this.d out
billionaire status will have to wait for
Iron Fist season two said she's been
confirmed to be joining that hacks or
maybe engage season 2 whatever comes
first
speaking of night nurses we finally get
a nod to the original the greatest night
nurse from the comics Lynda Carter well
it's an L Carter and she's the nurse on
call for mr. Knight who's recovering
from that loss of arm situation you can
see on the back there Lynda Carter is
most well known for her role in Doctor
Strange the elf a fantastic story that I
highly recommend all of them pick up we
did see Rachel McAdams portray another
version of the night nurse Christine
Palmer in Doctor Strange movie but maybe
this could lead to us meeting a version
of Lynda Carter
I'm really fine either way also there's
a dr. wertham written on that same board
that's the alter ego of a spider-man
villain named cardiac you can probably
guess his powers have met your face now
you're probably never going to see him
in the show or movies but hey spider-man
figurative obscure character Jessica
makes a joke of calling an iron fist
iron clad solid joke Jess what this is
actually a Marvel character because why
not a dude basically covered in metal
kind of a ripoff of colossus plastic for
marvel but don't expect him to show up
in your TV show
speaking of Jess we see the return yet
again of her alias investigations glass
window which we lost again it's between
the end of season 1 of Jessica Jones and
the start of the defenders maybe if she
should just put up a wood door and then
put a sticker on the outside anyways
this is a clear throwback to her alias
solo series and our classic office looks
just like it does for comics it's not
the worst place in the world either
let's just hope she just patches up that
hole in the wall where a mutant popped
average as for our daredevil sidekicks
we see here an extremely distraught
after the death of Matt which is a
totally understandable reaction but I
think this is also a nod to born again
when the most popular daredevil stories
which looks to be the inspiration for
season three get a little ahead of
myself our last shot on the show we see
Matt bandaged in the [ __ ] somewhere
unknown surrounded by nuns or someone
calls out for Megan oh I'll get into
what this means and at the end of the
video but just so you will know the
image is literally the cover of born
again which is also think of it as like
a rebirth story for there at all what
does that mean let's take a quick look
at some MCU Easter eggs at the show gave
us now there weren't too many but they
were still enough to make most of us
fans content some of them from the
movies but mostly from the other Netflix
shows I wish we had like a spider-man
cameo and maybe stay tuned near the
beginning of the show we see Danny
hunting for clues as to who destroyed
Kunlun if you don't remember the final
shot of season one of iron because Danny
discovers that the Sofia the prettiest
Emmet is gone where did you go we talked
about that though we see Luke meeting
with misty in Harlem and talking about
where shades and Mariah ended up at the
end of season one make sure you pay
attention though because if you look at
the bus advert in the background you may
notice the new Renaissance the
improvement project Mariah was using as
a perfect corner one for a pompous can't
wait to see those two again in season
two hottest it may have also noticed
them not to the loot cave series with
the Ginetta poster in that young man's
apartment in episode one didn't perform
back in cottonmouths club in season one
we also get a shot of alexandra sitting
on the same rooftop we saw the kingpin
all the way back in season would have
daredevil also worth mentioning that
same roof atop was in the first Sam
Raimi spider-man movie from spider-man
ties they don't stop here next receive
Augie and memory visit Josie's bar from
previous seasons of daredevil my guest I
hope at least is that we're going to see
just the Magra have a drink at this bar
and some features also one obscure not
to the MCU comes from the sward that
Danny and Colleen stare at for too long
the tus kimono sword this is actually a
nod to a famous Japanese director Shin
yet to sumoto why is the worth
mentioning well one of his most famous
movies would be Tetsu you da man there
you go suppose we'll get to Iron Man
being
Cirie's skew or to iron-fisted Luke
meeting for the first time by the way
this fight was awesome Epps saying Luke
barely move and any attacks him but I
also got the recreation of the face
punch from season where Luke Cage not
really sure how they think that but if
Mike Colter decided just to take the
punch like some actors have then also
fun to point out that we get a slight
not to Daredevils costume in season when
he Yanks away jessica scarpa creates a
makeshift mats I'm gonna be honest I do
prefer it to the new horn costume but
you know I love all the costumes
scooting forward again too when men is
visiting carrots office looking to sneak
her off to safety you notice that this
is in your office from season one in
there too well the very least Karen took
some of the frame newspapers from this
office and here is really the only MCU
connection we have in this series here
we get a mention of the incident in one
of the early episodes but here we see
the headlines from the Chitauri invasion
but also the attack in harlem for the
first Hulk movie and lastly it wouldn't
be a Marvel property without a Stan Lee
cameo blinking you're missing these
shows he's actually on the street in New
York would Matt in stalking Jessica and
Jessica the stalks map he's in a police
uniform on a poster just like in every
other Stanley not that we get in the
network shows I'm gonna be honest we
kind of isn't one of them he's not
actually playing an old guy apart
playing chess or something he's funny
he's charismatic man's them do something
now the coolest part of this show that I
loved so much was the production set
this on-camera work though
music the editing and most importantly
lighting you know I let's just start
with the lighting design of the show
because it's just so goddamn impressive
also I just want to point out a few
things that you may have missed
sure Matt's got red Jessica's got purple
Luke's got yellow and Danny's not green
we see in the first few episodes before
all of our heroes meet that each cut
away to where our heroes are at is lit
with each of their colors you can see it
here with the red and Matt's apartment
or when Luke gets off the bus in Harlem
and there's a yellow tint to the scene
even Danny's helicopter he's green as a
Christmas tree it is the most obvious
use of this was during the earthquake
sequence in the first episode dope
sequence not to criticize
too much though but why is this whole
section of New York green I got the
yellow from the streetlights and what
the read Because apartment in the purple
because of the TV screen not that
nitpick but like look at that there's a
whole section of a building that's just
purely green but even the lights in the
side of that building right there are
just green also there are too many
stairwells with flickering lights if you
guys want to be real heroes in New York
just reach up hop those babies right
back into place add some street-level
heroism but anyways as these heroes come
together the colors and the background
start to come together as well
especially during the Royal dragon
restaurant scene also worth mentioning
take a look at the dragon logo on the
outside of the restroom you can see that
all of the teams colors come together in
the neon pretty cool if you ask me I
like that that whole within the Royal
dragon you notice some of the characters
trading colors with each other like when
Luke and Jess are talking is in again
purple would just be bathed in the
yellow light tell me the next most
obvious use of color when Jess and
daredevil team will take on Murakami in
the room of red and purple I mean Matt
surprise entrance was kinda spoiled
because of the colors but hey it looks
awesome also I love the use of white to
signify Alexandra with her dated coat
saying in her rooms and meals might be
in a combination of all the colors
meaning that the heroes have to come
together to take her down unfortunately
electro copies the punch but hey at
least she looks good why also I enjoyed
that as the team works together the
colors sort of kind of disappear meaning
that they're working worth mentioning if
you notice carefully some of the
supporting casts of different shows how
hints of the show's colors in their
wardrobe specifically find Karen at the
end of the season also the transitions
in the show were top-notch using
different b-roll shots in New York with
different colors really made it feel
like this show was taking pieces of a
puzzle and building something new
exciting speaking cool shots
I love the sideways shot during the
opening of episode 2 when that goes out
to stop that shop owner from shooting
those kids feel like this symbolizes
that that's what you started to change
big-time also he's been working hard to
just be Matt bellick defense attorney
and that was a huge stress looming over
his city you might just have to rethink
his whole life and down the costume
what's also kind of see him walking with
that smoke that's being lit red is
possibly hinting to his return to the
costume lifestyle into the fun action
moment to point out Luke and Annie's
first few meetings during these scenes
the camera operator has the camera
pointed up at Luke and down at Danny
symbolizing their view of each other
kind of and possibly their maturity Luke
putting Danny in his place in the dojo
was one of the best scenes of the show
and once again they shot both characters
in the same way so notice what's hanging
behind Luke in the dojo a punching bag
it's the same color scheme that looks
hoodie obviously I'm not - Luke's a
fighting style and to me Terry sort of a
punching bag he can take a hit but he
never goes down something false I just
want to point out you guys probably got
it - but what stick is escaping the hand
an Electra he chops off his hand which
is one beyond that essence he's ancient
and then he climbs through an air
conditioning duct with only one hand but
- do you think this could possibly
symbolize this point out how awesome
stick is moving on to Danny being and
thundering dummy that's where the best
lines the shell immortal Iron Fist
living weapon and protector of the
ancient city is still hungry
dumbass Danny tries to take on the hand
by himself when you can notice that X
and respose at the end of the table
along with her outfit I feel this
definitely represents a dragon plenty
something how to take on a dragon to
gain the iron fist and the hand is
searching for a dragon below this very
building 2:30 but back to the Royal
dragon notice the murals behind Danny as
they eat in check dragon behind Danny
like the dragon Eve punched in the heart
today as iron fist but then behind Luke
you'll notice the Great Wall of China
illustrating these ability of
indestructible skin super cool to
mention some other music used earlier
but did you recognize what Matt was
playing on the piano which was hiding
the map of explosives
[Music]
it almost sounds like his own daredevil
theme but slightly different I believe
is actually playing a piece of the
defenders theme song which does have
hints of all the other themes within at
least one map speaking of music when
Alexandra's listening to a record player
it begins to skip and eventually she
must retire it is very clearly
representing her own life sure she's
been able to live life over and over
again but eventually everything must
come to an end the cycle must end and
one last little thing I'd like to
mention and also here comes another
spider-man reference to get ready when
we're in the underground lair of the
hidden door to the dragon the lighting
is exactly like Iron Fist green and
yellow costume obviously because he is
the key to open this magic door or the
come on wrote some stuff on but also
it's pretty awesome that Marvel chose to
play protect your neck by the wu-tang
Clank during this final battle because
it mentions our favorite whip it swing
it through your towel like your
neighborhood spider-man also RZA a
member of the wu-tang clan directed an
episode of iron fist and the unrelated
film the man with the iron fists comes
together in the end speaking of the end
what do you think of the future these
necklace show us what are we left with
after the defenders well coming back to
my previous theory and Danny's obvious
love of Matt's baton during that
interrogation scene I'm gonna guess
we're going to get some vigilante
episodes during season 2 of iron fist
not only that I think we might see Danny
take a page out of Matt's book and have
him make his own costume maybe even with
a scarf perhaps bring us closer to the
Iron Fist costume that we missed so much
from the defenders and season 1 of iron
fist as we can iron fist
we have Elektra mentioned that she may
or may not have had something to do with
tongue it's honestly very confusing when
she's saying it but my gut says that she
had
mainly because the rest of the hand
wanted to return to the city where'd it
go well since we now know that there has
been more than one dragon on earth I
think we might know who the culprit is
behind Puntland's disappearance in the
comics there's this dragon named chin
tank who's destroyed the city a
millennia ago out of anger and likes to
come back every now and again to destroy
it again now I have a feeling that
Netflix is listening to viewers and will
showcase a dragon next season in some
way so why not have the main antagonist
I know it's far-fetched but just hear my
pitch what if Jin Tang has been
gathering worshippers and followers for
centuries and with their help they
started to get some tunneling and
without the iron fist there to protect
them
city is transported somewhere else
during season two we have Daniel hunting
down this cult in reestablishing his
title as a protector of Kunlun by taking
out the rival dragon restore the city
I'd be down for it if the show has the
budget let me know your theories down
below notice with Luke and Jessica a
feeling that their stories are
relatively unaffected by these events -
that them maybe getting back together
however the daredevil crew is about to
get a lake now we know that Matt isn't
dead in with that I think it's fair to
say that Elektra is not dead either
possibly taken by the hand even though I
hope not a home for I'm not done with
them or take it by the same group of
none that have taken Matt how they got
them out of the cave and I will
definitely be confusing but there's more
to the scene with Matt in the bed like I
said before this is a direct recreation
of the cover of born again a popular
daredevil story where we meet Maggie
who's Maggie oh Justin that's mom born
again has been labeled as one of the
most important daredevil stories to date
and it really puts our characters
through the wringer it's sort of a
rebirth story for himself and his
friends during this comic we see Karen
go through a major drug addiction which
Matt helps her to get out of we get a
hint of her mental and emotional state
at the end of the season not being too
good and now that she's heading over to
the first season of Punisher I don't
think she's gonna be there
his camper comes season 3 in daredevil
and with that little ass little mention
of the Punisher we get a small teaser
for season 1 of this new Netflix Marvel
series coming out later this year no
exact date given but hey we got a couple
months left with just jam another season
in there we aren't given too much except
for that we'll be diving into Frank
castles past exploring his ties to the
military as well as his current mental
state and how he got here
so I don't think this shows going to be
very positive we see many gruesome
scenes with fellow soldiers and what I'm
guessing to be the death of his family
specifically we see his wife shot in the
head boy I'm gonna need some cartoons
when we're done with this show as we
know Karen page will making a few
appearances but also Ben Barnes from the
west-world of Fame as the villain jigsaw
aka Billy Russo normally jigsaw is a
spider-man villain but I am still
terrified to see him in the show I'm
sure we'll do a breakdown of the
official trailer once that hits the
internet but let us know what your
thoughts are on this little taste in the
comments down below but hey that's it
for me guys we made it I'm a little
sweaty but hey we made it
hope you enjoyed what do you guys think
of my theories in the Easter eggs that I
caught were there something I didn't
catch that I catch some that you may
have missed probably let me know in the
comments down below or on twitter at Sam
- I love when you guys tweet me your
thoughts and comments and whatnot give
this video a like if you haven't already
and subscribe to new rock stars for more
awesome breakdown and analyses of nerdy
stuff I hope to see you guys around soon
bye bye